bonsoir
vous avez déjà crié
alors j'imagine que oui
mais dans le doute on va tous crier
ensemble
ouais je vais compter jusqu'à 3 et après
ça vous allez tous crier très fort ouais
faites-moi confiance
deux
trois
et une dernière fois
vous ressentez l'énergie qu'il y a dans
la salle génial je vois des sourires sur
tout le monde et ça c'est cool et c'est
normal parce que le cri libère des
endorphines
ça c'est une hormone et c'est exactement
la même hormone qui est libérée dans
votre cerveau quand vous avez un fou
rire ou après une grosse séance de sport
ou après une forte douleur
et ce qui est génial c'est que cette
hormone a pour but d'apaiser votre corps
pour éviter une panique extrême
et elle vous permet aussi d'être plus
concentré d'être d'avoir plus de force
et aussi de d'être plus calme évidemment
alors ma théorie préférée autour de ça
ça serait que dans l'évolution en fait
quand nos ancêtres devaient crier ça
veut dire que quelque chose de pas ouf
est en train de se passer et donc qu'ils
étaient probablement en danger et donc
il criait et avec le temps le cerveau
aurait associé le cri avec le mode
survie
et donc aujourd'hui quand on crie il y
aurait des restes de ça ce qui explique
pourquoi quand on crie ça libère dans
l'endorphine ça nous booste on est plus
concentré etc
mais la raison pour laquelle je vous ai
fait crier
c'est parce que ça illustre parfaitement
ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui qui est
la peur d'interagir avec les autres
alors aujourd'hui je suis capable de
monter sur scène et de faire crier que
des gens que je ne connais absolument
pas
je suis capable de parler à un inconnu
dans la rue simplement parce que j'en ai
envie
et je suis capable d'aller dans des
soirées où je ne connais personne et
parler à tout le monde
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
non
quand j'étais petit j'étais un grand
timide en fait à chaque fois que je
devais avoir une interaction sociale
avec quelqu'un
j'étais terrifié
je vais pas que la personne me trouve
ridicule qu'elle me trouve bizarre ou
inintéressant
je sais pas dire bonjour au chauffeur de
bus quand je montais
je sais pas regarder les gens dans les
yeux
ce qui est très bizarre pendant une
discussion
et à chaque fois que je devais passer un
coup de téléphone même si c'était pour
appeler la pizzeria du coin je répétais
en boucle encore et encore et encore la
phrase exacte que je devais prononcer
pour être sûr de pas bégayer et ça
terminait souvent par mois qui demande à
ma sœur d'appeler à ma place
et la plus grande erreur
c'est quand on devait se présenter en
classe
vous savez le fameux salut moi c'est
Charlie j'ai 13 ans et j'adore faire du
piano l'angoisse
et je rougissais et rouge et encore très
facilement à tel point que j'avais le
rotophobie la phobie de devenir rouge en
public
bref tout ça pour dire que j'étais un
grand timide mais un jour j'ai découvert
un concept
le mentalisme
alors pour faire très simple le
mentalisme c'est un mélange de
psychologie et d'illusionnisme qu'on
utilise en général pour bluffer les gens
et pour les comprendre
mais plutôt que de vous faire une
explication un peu longue et un peu un
peu chiante je vous propose de faire une
expérience tous ensemble ça sera plus
fun et plus intéressant alors vous allez
tous penser à l'un de vos plus grands
rêves quelque chose que vous aimez que
vous avez envie de réaliser ou peut-être
que vous êtes déjà en train de réaliser
ça peut être quelque chose de très très
simple si vous l'avez déjà en tête levez
la main
et lever la main bien haut il me faut
quelqu'un de très précis
contrairement c'est comment
Zachary est-ce que je peux me rejoindre
sur scène super on peut applaudir très
fort Zachary s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
ça va
je suis simplement me donner des
informations personnelles sur toi rien
de très très personnel t'inquiète pas et
je devrais être capable de me rapprocher
plus ou moins
alors fais-moi juste confiance tu vas
juste répondre aux questions que je te
pose la voix haute quel âge as-tu
21 ans OK
frère et sœur
trois sœurs
ok ça c'est intéressant
pas dans le sens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est quoi ton futur métier où ton
métier potentiel
OK et si tu avais un métier que
peut-être que dont tu rêvais quand tu es
des gosses ça serait quoi
pizza alors c'est peut-être toi le gars
dont j'avais peur d'appeler il y a un
monde ok alors tu vois là tu vas
communiquer des informations verbalement
c'est très intéressant et tu mets là
aussi communiquer de façon non verbale
quand ta démarche tu vois pour me
rejoindre sur scène ça donne des infos
de ta façon de regarder les gens aussi
ta façon de me répondre également et ça
c'est cool et
et donc ce qui est intéressant c'est
quand on se renseigne un peu sur le plus
grand rêve des gens ou les choses que
les gens ont envie de faire dans leur
vie on se rend compte qu'il y a pas
10000 possibilités alors avec toutes les
informations que j'ai sur toi je vais
tenter d'écrire quelque chose qui
devrait s'en rapprocher j'espère
OK
je suis en train d'écrire sa vie les
gars là actuellement ok on va faire ça
et je vais
OK et je lui préciser quelque chose
quand même je m'excuseras pour
l'écriture
OK
mais vous aurez l'idée j'espère que ça
passe OK est-ce que tu peux me dire s'il
te plaît ou est fort le rêve que tu
avais en tête la chose que tu voulais
réaliser
j'allais faire un show en parachute seul
on est bon merci beaucoup Zacharie tu
peux être à ce soir merci
[Applaudissements]
OK
comment les gens détournent un peu le
regard
là vous avez une idée un peu plus
précise de ce qu'est le mentalisme
et c'est pour moi il devait toute
première représentation de mentalisme
que j'ai compris quelque chose de fort
sur le regard et le jugement des autres
c'était un samedi soir devant
une scène de quelques centaines de
personnes j'allais faire ma toute
première vraie scène de mentalisme alors
évidemment j'étais hyper stressé mais ma
passion pour le mentalisme m'a permis
d'aller au-delà de ça
et j'avais 5 numéros à faire les trois
premiers numéros c'est pas super bien et
en faisant le quatrième
je rate complètement devant tout le
monde
alors évidemment à ce moment-là j'étais
très gêné je sentais mon visage chauffé
mon cœur s'accélérer et j'ai réussi à
faire tant bien que mal une transition
pour arriver sur le cinquième numéro qui
lui heureusement se passe bien
alors à ce moment là je me dis que tout
le monde a trouvé ça nul nique les gens
m'ont jugé et vont me juger ils ont pas
dû passer un bon moment j'ai mis tout le
monde mal à l'aise
et ma plus grande surprise à la fin du
spectacle tout le monde applaudit et se
lève
alors évidemment je ne comprends pas
donc je me dis que j'ai besoin de savoir
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là
dans leur tête alors je suis allé voir
les gens à la sortie du théâtre discuter
avec eux et personne ne m'a parlé de mon
échec tout le monde me parlait de ce
moment qui les avait fait rire c'est
Maman qui les avait touchés ou encore
celui qui les avait bluffé
mais tout le monde semblait avoir oublié
ce quatrième numéro
tout le monde était peut-être très sympa
mais c'est là qu'un spectateur
s'approche de moi et vient de dire
quelque chose de quelque chose qui m'a
marqué vraiment félicitations bravo
j'aurais jamais osé faire ça moi
alors
cette phrase c'est cette phrase là qui
peut paraître si banale qui a créé en
moi un déclic cette personne venait de
me faire comprendre quelque chose de
très fort
et c'est quelque chose que j'applique
depuis au quotidien et qui m'aide à oser
malgré ma peur
cette chose
la voici
quand vous interagissez avec quelqu'un
la personne ne se concentre pas sur vous
mais sur elle-même
elle se dit est-ce que je peux aller
parler à cette personne ou est-ce que je
suis assez intéressant où est-ce que
cette personne est assez intéressante
pour moi je n'aurais jamais osé faire ça
moi
je
l'extrême majorité des cas
la personne se concentre sur ses peurs
ses émotions c'est ressenti et c'est
normal mais si tout le monde se dit
qu'est-ce que les autres pensent de moi
alors ça veut dire que tout le monde se
concentre sur soi-même
et que paradoxalement personne ne se
concentrer réellement sur vous
imaginez un inconnu vient vous parler là
vous aurez deux réactions possibles soit
vous allez le trouver sympa et vous
aurez envie de discuter encore avec lui
soit vous le trouvez un petit peu relou
et vous aurez envie de partir
dans le premier cas vous vous
souviendrez de lui positivement dans le
deuxième cas vous n'oublierez très
rapidement
pour vous concentrer sur votre vie
et bien c'est la même chose quand nous
interagissons avec les autres
la façon dont nous réagissons avec les
autres c'est la façon dont les autres
réagissent avec nous et c'est pour ça
que quand on sort de chez le coiffeur on
se dit que tout le monde va remarquer la
coupe de cheveux qu'on a qu'on a à
nouveau alors que si c'est pas
radicalement différent personne ne s'en
rend compte et c'est exactement pour ça
que quand j'ai fait ce quatrième numéro
personne ne la notifié mon échec parce
que les gens ne se concentrent pas sur
la réussite ou pas de mon numéro mais il
se concentre sur ce qu'il ressentait
pendant mon spectacle et globalement
dans l'ensemble ils ont eu un ressenti
plutôt positif donc ils ont passé un bon
moment
donc en fait on amplifie dans notre tête
le regard des autres
et ça c'est un nom
ça s'appelle l'effet Spotlight vous les
fait projecteur
et il y a un docteur le Docteur Thomas
gilovic j'espère que je prononce bien
qui a fait une étude super
ment et l'idée est très simple il prend
des participants il leur demande de
porter des t-shirts sur lesquels étaient
imprimés des visages de personnalités
publiques comme le visage de Bob Marley
par exemple il demande à ses
personnes d'aller se balader autour du
d'une foule autour de plein de gens et à
la fin de l'expérience il leur demande
d'estimer le nombre de personnes qui
pensent avoir remarqué leur T-shirt
tous les participants ont surestimé de
plus de 5 fois le nombre réel
donc si on extrapole ça veut juste dire
qu'on amplifie complètement et qu'on
su-estime complètement le regard des
autres sur nous et la réalité de ce qui
se passe en fait
et comprendre ça
ça a été libérateur pour moi
parce que j'ai réalisé que je pouvais
aller parler aux autres sans réelle
conséquence je pouvais enfin faire et
dire ce que je voulais de toute façon
les gens n'apportent pas tant
d'importance que ça à ce que je raconte
et au pire je passe deux minutes
désagréable parce que je dis quelque
chose de stupide et la personne l'aura
complètement oublié d'ici peu et au
mieux je débloque le pouvoir de parler à
n'importe qui
alors c'est pour ça que je peux être
devant vous aujourd'hui parce que je
sais très bien d'ici deux semaines
maximum vous mourrez tous oubliés pour
penser à vos peurs vos échecs vos
réussites
et je dis pas que j'ai plus peur parce
que la peur c'est ça c'est normal
d'avoir peur c'est bon c'est un
mécanisme de défense du corps ça veut
dire qu'on est en bonne santé donc le
but c'est pas de ne plus avoir peur
non le vrai but c'est de comprendre
comment surmonter sa peur
et pour être honnête quand j'étais assis
juste là avant j'avais peur ouais
j'étais vraiment stressé de venir
chanter mon cœur s'accélérait j'espérais
ne pas rougir
mais j'ai osé parce que je me rappelle
que je ne suis qu'un personnage
secondaire de la vie des autres
et si je fais TEDx parce que j'aimerais
vous transmettre ce courage d'oser agir
pour parler à n'importe qui que ce soit
amical amoureux ou professionnel
alors je pense pas être plus courageux
qu'un autre je pense que j'ai juste
adopté la bonne façon de penser pour
agir
et c'est cette façon de penser que
j'aimerais vous transmettre maintenant à
travers trois clés qui m'ont grandement
aidé
et que vous pourrez mettre en pratique
dès la fin de ce toc
clé numéro 1
concentrez-vous sur l'autre quand vous
parlez avec quelqu'un quand vous
interagissez avec cette personne ou si
vous voulez interagir avec
concentrez-vous sur ce que la personne
pourrait potentiellement ressentir
est-ce qu'elle a l'air stressée à l'aise
angoissée ou détendu
ça aura deux effets ça vous rendra plus
empathique et ça diminuera aussi dans
votre tête l'importance que vous pensez
que cette personne vous accorde
et ça c'est cool parce que vous pourrez
plus facilement agir
deuxième clé ne réfléchissez pas trop
votre cerveau est une machine à éviter
de vous faire souffrir il a été
programmé pour ne pas que vous souffriez
en tout cas pour faire au maximum en
sorte que vous ne le faites pas et donc
c'est pour ça que quand on a peur
il va trouver tout un tas d'histoires
crédibles pour vous empêcher d'affronter
votre peur et donc vous empêcher de
souffrir
il va se dire je peux pas aller parler à
cette personne parce qu'à l'air occupée
je peux pas aller parler à cette
personne c'est pas le bon endroit où je
peux pas aller lui parler parce que j'ai
rien d'intéressant à lui dire
mais ces histoires crédibles ça
s'appelle des excuses
et
votre cerveau est une machine à
ce qui est marrant c'est que le meilleur
moyen d'éviter ces excuses et c'est
dedans en avoir
alors pour ça quand vous sentez que vous
avez peur prenez une grande inspiration
concentrez-vous sur l'instant sur vos
sens sur ce que vous ressentez sur ce
que vous entendez ce que vous voyez ce
que vous touchez
et ça aura pour un effet savoir un effet
très simple qui est de couper votre
cerveau de saturer votre cerveau pour
l'empêcher de réellement réfléchir donc
de réellement penser à votre peur et
encore une fois ça vous permettra de
plus facilement agir
et troisième et dernière clé celle qui
m'a le plus aidé
plus tu vas te rapprocher rapidement
d'une peur
plus elle va diminuer
en fait c'est simplement faire une
action très simple qu'on se sent capable
de faire
quand l'exemple très simple quand
j'étais en école d'ingénieur parce que
j'étais en école d'ingénieur avant de
faire du mentalisme je j'allais parler
aux gens dans la rue tous les mercredis
après-midi je sortais pour essayer de
parler des inconnus parce que je sais
pas faire ça et du coup à chaque fois
que j'allais parler à un inconnu
je stressé et donc j'ai adopté une
méthode très simple pour éviter de faire
ça je me dis marche et comme dans ta
tête
juste marcher
et quand tu arrives devant la personne
cet ami dans une dynamique d'action qui
fait que ton cerveau à moins peur et du
coup de toute façon tu vas lui parler
parce que c'est beaucoup plus gênant de
ne rien dire que de ne pas parler tu
vois donc tu vas forcément lui parler et
c'est comme ça que tu te mets à discuter
avec des inconnus
alors
si vous appliquez ces trois clés
ça vous permettra de diminuer votre peur
de parler aux autres d'interagir avec
eux et qui sait peut-être que un jour
vous aurez envie de monter sur scène et
de faire crier des gens que vous ne
connaissez pas et rien ne vous en
empêchera mais que vous appliquez la clé
numéro 1 en vous concentrant sur l'autre
la clé numéro 2 en vous concentrant sur
vous-même ou la clé numéro 3 en faisant
une toute petite action
l'idée derrière et la même
libérez-vous et osez parler à qui vous
voulez
parce que
vous agissez pour vous-même pas pour les
autres peut-être qu'un personnage
secondaire de la vie des autres
et si je vous demande de devenir le
réalisateur de la vôtre vous me
répondrez un
deux trois